none of the stunts are supposed to be
dangerous but that was quite a scary
stunt what you guys did there spidey
life is tough work
welcome to the world of filming
spider-man where there were endless
tricky scenes that left actors battered
bruised and seriously shook at the end
of it which actor collapsed to the
ground immediately after filming an
intense fight let's dive in
number one living a double life is tough
and tom holland had the bruises to show
for it and lucky for you we've got the
footage to show we get a bit of a risky
business throwback in this scene but tom
isn't so smooth as what we see on camera
it took a few takes for him to nail it
in the end but having all that furniture
to run through well it was clearly far
from easy and that furniture was not
gonna work around him number two
it was never an easy fight both tom
holland and toby maguire have had to
face off with the green goblin but tom's
face off with him during no way home
left both parties totally spent tom
called it one of the most intense fights
of the film so it's no surprise to hear
both willem and tom wiped out collapsing
to the ground after the cameras stopped
rolling tom even said i remember my
knuckles were all bloody and i was
knackered but we kept fighting and
fighting it was awful we're exhausted
just watching these two go at it
honestly
but for tom it was worth it in the end
because
in the film it's so spectacular and it
is so overwhelming number three good
things take time we will never be able
to get the vision of the three spideys
on top of the crown on the statue of
liberty out of our heads but it was far
from easy to achieve according to
holland the shot where we all land on
the crown is one of the hardest
spider-man landings i've ever done
because the crown was just so uneven and
in the spider-man suit you can't see
anything and i was really trying to land
in the most iconic spider-man pose we
thank you for your service spider-mans
number four it's never easy not even for
a season stunt performer car stunts do
make for your dangerous days on set but
toss in doing acrobatic flips off of
moving cars oh yeah all while giving the
performance of your life well tom was on
it and somehow he overcame this
incredibly tricky sequence it really was
awesome to like explore different kind
of spider-man action he had a harness on
for safety but that didn't make the job
any easier number five it's tough to
stick every landing no one knows this
better than zendaya and tom holland who
struggled to nail one particular scene
spider-man swings us on top of a bridge
and he places me there the dynamic duo
wasn't always in great shape since well
we've all noticed their height
difference i would land before him my
feet obviously hit the ground before he
does tom really had to rely on zendaya
to hold her own in this one but that
wasn't a problem for her at all still
nailing the shot overall was a bit of a
struggle
number six but it wasn't a great
vacation tom had to step back from
filming completely for a bit after
seriously busting up his knee when
filming no way home i've hurt my knee so
they've given me a few days off the
action sequence he was shooting was a
serious and very literal pain to deal
with tom did say you're going to see a
style of fighting in this movie that
you've never seen in a spider-man movie
before they designed these fights to
shock you guys and that they did but tom
had to pay the price when he was ready
to go back on set again every scene
became just a bit harder with the fear
that he'd aggravate his knee and be
forced to take time off again number 7
only some of the water was cg
unfortunately for tom the major blast
was practically shot far from home left
tom in rough shape pretending he was
struggling and suffering for the cameras
was easy enough but mentally getting
through that overwhelming shot well it
was a tricky one to say the least
filming on location is great except when
it involves nearly drowning number eight
cue uncomfortable elevator music stunt
work is often pretty tricky but filming
in this elevator shaft set made for an
extra difficult and long day on set
there were some strings attached but tom
still brought this performance to life
despite the complexity he was working
through and he looks good doing it too
he's spider-man for a reason number nine
you know the one the best and possibly
worst part of being pals with spider-man
has got to be the impromptu tarzaning
through skyscrapers zendaya and tom went
head to head with a hundred and ten foot
jump with the help of a crane setup to
help them achieve the shot what's really
a shame is the fact that they did in
fact capture this incredibly difficult
stunt film
but they didn't wind up using it at all
instead the team re-shot the sequence
with much lower stakes we're talking
jumping into some cardboard boxes from a
significantly lower level and that's the
footage we got in the final cut
still we gotta give tom and zendaya
credit for facing the difficulty head on
and it looks better i don't know
number 10 floaties can't help him here
the spider-man suit is good for a lot of
things
including capturing and holding water
inside of it unfortunately that's not so
useful and in fact just made tom's
experience filming the scene in
spider-man homecoming a total nightmare
it looks amazing it feels terrible
waterboarding himself just for the sake
of the scene was a selfless act but
maybe not such a great one in the end
number eleven
that's gotta hurt jacob battalon had a
dislocated shoulder and yet he still
decided to do a scene that featured him
holding on to scaffolding this made
filming what was an already tough scene
even tougher we're kind of surprised the
crew let him do it considering what a
safety risk it had posed what if ned had
been taken down for the count even
longer we can't have had that
number 12.
it was not cute
tom holland's pretty face got real torn
up wearing his spidey helmet during
pretty much all of far from home this
made any scene with the mask way tougher
than it had to be thankfully the marvel
crew had his back and eventually updated
the design so tom's suffering could
finally end i ended up cutting my face
at one point on it it just wasn't a very
good design number 13.
not so much it's called special safety
equipment but it actually turned out to
not be so safe to use sure it kept her
from having a really bad accident while
filming stunts for the amazing
spider-man 2 but emma stone didn't leave
the set unscathed for the actress the
harnesses were super uncomfortable to
wear which made filming all those stunts
a real pain and she was left with some
nasty bruising too number 14
burn baby burn so running for a shot
isn't so hard but toss in the fact that
the destination was a real burning
building he was in wild amounts of
danger cause well fire but he gave it
his all and came through mostly
unscathed though we doubt he was much of
a fan of fire after that number 15. it's
famous for a reason toby mcguire
seriously struggled with drowning inside
his mask while upside down
it seems like this problem has been
around for a long time toby overcame the
struggle and luckily for him it did make
an impact imagine if people didn't even
like the scene he probably struggled the
most with
did anyone really think filming the
spider-man movies would be easy
with great power comes great
responsibility but facing that
responsibility when it involves such
difficult scenes to film
well it's tough to do but no surprise
this crew pulled on through as per usual
which scene do you think would have been
the trickiest to shoot